alo alo cho bạn
LUV ừ
a cho các bạn thấy là
À hôm trước và hôm nay nó cùng chung một
cái tước đề và kiểu
cho sự thì hôm trước Đúng là mình cũng
chẳng dậy được cái gì mấy nói qua được
thêm một tí thôi may mà có cái có hỏi
các bạn hỏi thì mình nói có một tí
Vậy là cũng không có cái gì để mà trả
lời mấy
cơ bản thì nhớ cái buổi như thế này nó
lại rất là phổ biến giống cái hồi trước
mà tôi cho sinh viên làm nó oán nghĩa
sinh viên cần tập trung làm đồ án thì
tôi không kiểu dạng lại không dạy nhiều
mà không dậy nhiều mấy nữa mà ngày ngày
thì có là kiểm tra Sinh viên Xem sinh
viên có cần hỗ trợ gì mà làm không Chứ
không
ngày ngày dậy thêm kiến thức mới ra sinh
viên cũng hơi chán bởi vì ngày nào phải
đến trường xong rồi cùng thì chẳng dậy
thêm cái gì cả mà cốt là kiểm tra
kiểm tra tiến độ của của cái đồ án nhiều
sinh viên thì muốn làm tại nhà Nếu không
được ra thì làm tại nhà nó
thứ nhất là các thầy sẽ không kiểm soát
được là sinh viên tiến trình đang như
thế nào thứ hai là các bạn là mẹ nhà đôi
khi các bạn bị lười Hải Vân nhiều cái
hoặc cả các bạn
các bạn không nạp được với nhóm nhé các
bạn làm tại nhà thì các bạn là một mình
mà nó không ạ ạ Thế nên là vẫn bắt miên
đến và cho sinh viên quen với việc là
việc đến công ty đôi khi về sau nó sẽ
thế có một vài công ty giống như là hiện
tại công ty tôi thí ra còn thoải mái làm
tại nhà nhưng đôi khi cũng vẫn phải lên
lên công ty
anh Bởi vì à Nhiều lúc là mình sẽ không
phải làm việc một mình mà mình sẽ làm
việc với người khác nên là mình phải
quen với việc à Có nên công ty thì thỉnh
thoảng có ai có hỏi đáp gì thì mình có
thể xử lý trợ giúp được luôn
trước việc mình ở nhà người ta liên lạc
mình khó kết là việc là có thể là mấy
ông ở nhà thì nó sáng lên Nếu không làm
giờ hành chính đâu Nói thẳng như thế Kể
lại sử dụng máy chấm công nữa khi mấy
ông vẫn nhiều làm ở nhà kia chấm Chuyển
điểm danh xong đi ngủ nên thành ra là
kiểu à
ai
ngờ cậu bé ông sẽ khó mà liên lạc được
còn nên công ty thì tác phong của mọi
thứ tôi sẽ đàng hoàng hơn
nên nên theo sunpad hay Mobile cái này
mình nghĩ là bạn cứ
thử mỗi cái một tí thì bạn mới biết được
thực sự mình hợp phù hợp cái gì ăn mì
thì ra là
con là nó nếu mà theo khăn ở đây sẽ có
tận 2 ý hiểu là làm như kiểu là thiết kế
theo dạng làm giao diện hay làm kiểu xử
lý như quán em Nhưng mà thường mà chẳng
ai làm chỉ xử lý phân em cả mặt thường
sẽ kết hợp với cả bác em nữa còn làm bác
em thì đôi khi chỉ cần chuẩn bác em thôi
mà mua là Mobile thì nó sẽ kiêm cả hai
cả futech cả bạn cả bát thường người như
thế khi bé theo tôi ạ Nhớ như thế
anh nói chung à Bạn cứ học qua cái cơ
bản đã qua cơ bản lập trình đã thử xem
phù hợp hay không đã rồi bạn thầy Thích
có thể học cả một vài ngôn ngữ gì đó để
xem ngôn ngữ nào cảm thấy mình dễ học
nhiều cái
tính năng chung không mấy cái tính năng
mà tất cả Ozil đều dùng được theo ra thì
đấy cũng là một cái lý do mà kiểu có
sinh ra thằng các Zalo tên là con trâu
lâu còn mấy thì mình Excel kế thừa nói
thì các bạn hãy viết vào trong ngày
extend ấy do các bạn gọi doris gọi đến
cái thớt chung đấy là được
à à
ừ ừ
từ những nhận
ở những nhóm nào cần chữa thì bình luận
nhé à
lên được không
sáng
[âm nhạc]
use the weather that person countries
are you were afraid of Snow White to
hell Máy tao bị pha bởi vì em
mà like
đánh lừa rồi nhắn tin hiểu được hôm nay
cái này khi mẹ ra nó hôm nào mình Kiss
me some countries
or
cái video này vừa nói qua việc à nếu mà
mình dịch thu Hero là anh không đôi khi
nó cũng đúng
Anh Hello Ở đây chỉ là người mình ngưỡng
mộ mình muốn trở thành thôi Thì
cái này đó vừa để cập anh ngày vừa đề
cập Nó là kiểu ạ
sau khi mà ai đó hỏi mình ngưỡng mộ một
ai mình có thần tượng một ai
khi
hiểm thì mình đôi khi mình sẽ nói là đại
giống nhanh Nhật Bản nó bản thân mình 10
năm nữa thấy cả thế và mình tiếp tục sẽ
phấn đấu cơ thể thế mình sẽ không ở trạm
đến 10 năm nữa bởi vì
Hì hì nhất là mình sẽ không một dẫn cho
lại chỗ mình sẽ luôn thay đổi thứ hai là
mình sẽ có một cái mục tiêu gì đó để
phấn đấu cái nghĩa ngay từ trong những
câu nói anh đấy anh biết được là mình sẽ
không mơ hoàn hảo nhưng mà mình sẽ luôn
tiếp tục phấn đấu để trở thành tốt hơn
nếu phải dẫn cho lại chỗ làm như tôi
cũng đừng ai nói với ông đó là
đôi khi chúng ta không nên so sánh bản
thân mình bất kỳ ai mà Sạch với chính
bản thân mình trong quá khứ sao Mình ở
thay đổi những gì nhưng là anh này cũng
có một ý hay nữa Đó là kiểu hợp khí A So
sánh bản thân mình với tương lai đấy
mình sẽ phấn đấu để sao cho kiểu để đạt
được cái gì đó để về sau tương lai mình
Ừ mai mình luôn tốt hơn luôn phấn đấu
hơn nó là muốn thứ mà mình ngưỡng mộ
kiểu thế tấm chưa cậu giống nha Bây giờ
tôi 25 tuổi
mẹ tôi lúc bắt luôn tự tin ở tôi 30 tuổi
sẽ rất là gọi là trùng thành hơn chín
chắn hơn gọi là thành công hơn nhiều cái
thì đấy tôi sẽ luôn thận Tôi sẽ luôn cố
trở thành người như thế trong vòng 5 ban
30 tuổi không ạ sau đó thì đến con mốc
30 tuổi rồi thì thôi thì nói mẹ 5 năm
nữa đấy cứ đặt cún mốc 55 Vào một cột
mốc ở nó quan trọng và ông nghĩ à một
lúc đấy nó sẽ là một cột mốc
một cái cột mốc trong cuộc đời đôi khi ở
liên quan đến
nó khi thường ngày đặt ở đây like kiểu
nhưng vẫn tuổi tác như thế
từ khóa có liên quan đến kiểu một cái gì
đó Nhưng mà thường tuổi tác bởi vì tuổi
tác nó sẽ ảnh hưởng rất nhiều
những cái video đấy tôi vẫn nghĩa ở mình
có vẻ mình đang đi đúng Mình cũng đang
nghĩ rồi như nhiều người cũng gọi là
thành công Đấy người ta đang cầm cái
tượng gì gì đó mà họ nói gì Chẳng đúng
ở nhóm kia đúng không nhớ xem nhé
Mở Zalo
à à
Ừ cái này Facebook nếu không thì tap2a
anh không không không không nên làm hàng
nó không kiểu tí teo như này
Ẩm
Thực ra là buổi trưa Tôi đọc một cái đó
hạn chế Dung eo nhất có thể thấy gần
nhất
thứ hai đó là em có thể tách Cái này nó
là Kiều bucket step 1 book cùng set 2
đổi cho dễ hiểu OOO
ạ Và nếu rõ nói rõ hơn mà bản chất là
cái này liên quan đến nữa hả Tính kịch
đồng loạn
anh gọi liên quan home page ở đấy Nhưng
bản chất ở Liên đoàn tích cực thì nó sẽ
là kiểu Ý
nên đặt tên nhà nghỉ ở
mấy cái này điền thông tin Phan ban đầu
này
thì nó sẽ là kiểu info
ạ sau đó đi mới bắt đầu muốn chọn
một tí tí
Ừ dạo này xử lý quá lằng nhằng có phức
tạp ở trong một controller
để xem nào
em cho anh sex nhiều quá
này nó vô đây là trang của người
dù người ta lại phải virus có thử format
lại đẹp không tí nha yêu thương là để mà
khi mà ít xét nhiều như thế này tôi sẽ
thưởng lên kịp Để hẳn xuống xuống hẳn
như thế này nhìn nó rõ này
khi test bằng mode tại sao lưu step Bằng
1/2 ngày đầu tiên à router Perry
bí quyết này
I started xi TN
a c pro ở Sài Gòn cài đặt này lên tách
hai câu cái Saclo cái này trong cái CF
pro cái này
tiếp theo led Trôi
A Goodbye
and thereby Tại sao đây ở cà liên quan
đến tấm giá Ok Google Drive đến said C ở
nhà
sau đó thì map lấy từng thăm
a black không
ừ ừ
khi cài 34 lấy à tên của thằng đầu tiên
đúng không Thì thực ra là ngay
ở ngay từ đầu cái đoạn này start này
ô tô từ nếu mà
Ừ nếu bạn muốn lấy một thằng thôi thì
không cần phải mất công ạ Dùng cái gọi
đến had many như thế này
Anh tên nhất ở Harmony thứ nhất phải
thêm chữ s ở đây là hai đó là
mô tô của Sistar
nhật nó sẽ phải là
belonged tô chứ
anh không tốt không dậy nét đâu
à Anh nhầm rồi Cái này bị long tôi nhỉ
Sistar ID mà ông bị nhầm à
xe trượt ở ở
khi bị non Tùng ơi
Ừ nó mới như này mới chuẩn chứ
lấy lên mà đúng không em sẽ chỉ cần à
hình ảnh này
à à
ở cái đoạn này lại say nữa này cái này
Android rồi so sánh với luôn được à
chứ vấn này lấy ra một một thằng Mà nó
lại phải dùng ghét lắp xong rồi ông
dùng phát về luôn chứ không rút Bike làm
gì nhỉ
A Goodbye chẳng nghĩa gì đây khi mà
Ê
mày có chút vẫn là sai hết rồi
bé thằng đầu tiên thì có thể cho thằng
như thế này này
a
sad day sao nói bây giờ kiểm tra nếu mà
khác luôn thì mình thể ngược lại nhà
It's luôn này à
a number sắc tinh là cái gì
gái trưởng tổ cức mẹo làm hạn chế hạn
này cả
em
heo nó sẽ chỉ lấy giá vào ngày thôi
ừ ừ
định Lúc đầu như thế này sau đó em như
thế này ra được
95 persistent này ông trở về nó là
đi để trở về kiểu số Trinh này
hình ảnh sét này thì gộp lại này
Ừ thế thôi kệ vậy từ tách ra ngoài đấy
báo lỗi đấy
có phải Cốt
ở Tab
à à
vì nó gợi ý các thứ ấy
kiểm tra điều kiện không nó đã
em không đủ đủ so sánh với cả luôn rồi
đôi khi nó không
anh không hay lắm đâu ạ
rồi hả Em chuyển lại đi quét à
không không làm kiểu này
Ở tập thể dục không nên làm kiểu này ồ
mp7 cái
an toàn bộ những cái mà người dùng đã
tìm kiếm này lên 2 địa chỉ sau đó thì em
mà em có thể cho khi mà chuyển sang
trang khác thì em chèn thêm cái ạ Tết
mày nằm trong thành địa chỉ truyền lên
chứ không phải ghi tên là cái view như
này à
à à
sự vô tâm mà không cần tải
ừ ừ
lúc Kali này rồi Lúc ở đây này vãi
chưởng
à à
Ừ cái này đang bạn quá rồi à
Ừ nếu mà không rõ mà
Xem các video khác lấy không được bằng
rỗng thì tại sao phải xử lý đoạn này
lằng nhằng thế
a cho bằng luôn rồi mà
ngày đi
ghét Twitter anh
gọi đây là chuỗi rỗng ra xử với em muốn
hiểu biết được cậu lại ngay
khi hát xong
a case Tab em
sau khi tao ở không hiểu là cái gì cho
ca Chắc thế
ờ Guetta love you
à à
anh nhìn cứ voi thật là đáng sợ
khi bị loại này là sợ thật
anh bằng lớn hơn thời gian này nhỏ hơn
thời gian này
Ừ thế này thì tính là bitoon nằm trong
khoảng này á khác đến bằng các em nhỏ
hơn ok
a Where that ve snacks Tôi thường gọi
điện selec nằm trên cho nằm giữa cho nó
quen làm dưới cùng
A và snack không nên ghi độ cách nhau
dấu phẩy rồi các thứ thứ như này
ừ ừ
a Where ai để làm gì nhỉ lấy ra xong web
phát nữa cái cái này đoạn này nếu mà em
quay ở đây nó đôi khi nó sẽ càng xa anh
nhé Nó lại em lấy ra rồi sau đó em que
phát nữa thì à
có khi nó khác với việc là em quay ở
trên này nhá quay trên này nó sẽ trong
câu truy vấn còn quen này em sẽ dùng TP
dùng Gallery tìm và xử lý xử lý
Collection này khi mà ghét bản chất là
sẽ trả lời có listen sau đó thì em chạy
các từ thứ xong rồi em qua nha không nên
z bài
giờ xuống phải kiểm tra à
em quay do được để lấy jimenez mà
cho iPhone này ở đâu
chắc chắn nằm trong bớt thì em có thể à
weather để em lấy luôn cái đoạn đấy để
ngay ngay trong này không cần lấy que
không cần phải đếm lại như này rồi que
quan đến nhiều nhiều bảng quá nên thành
ra là câu chuyện về không em đang hơi bị
loạn theo cái này anh sẽ gọi riêng để xử
lý cho à
wifi này của bạn đấy Nó kiểu đọc
chính xa Cái này dùng để lọc rồi nó
không đúng cái này phải à order bye
prices hoặc coderbyte cái gì đó thì nó
hợp lý hơn bản chất ở đây em chỉ có một
kẻ order bye thôi Đây là em sẽ truyền
cái biến alright lên để hiểu là mình sẽ
sắp xếp theo phải gì sẽ chuyển giá sẽ
thì cái gì nó hợp lý
em mà em lại ra hết rồi mà em mới que
thì nó đôi khi không được đúng là lắm
mai ở đây là em đang dùng lấy hết chỗ em
mà phân trang cái hợp với quay như này
nó xảy ra có thể trang đầu em chẳng có
dữ liệu gì cả thôi trai mình có dữ liệu
vì bản chất là em lấy ra hết rồi người
que thì nó không đúng
nhé Ok
a location
Metal Grey Black location
theo thì bạn này khiến ai bị sai bạn này
em phải với đích lại bản chất là cái
đoạn này nó bảo rồi Cái này nếu em tắt
nó hai cái mới thốt một cái mới thất lúc
bút tích kiệm TechOne cũng được là một
cái Mochi Book that su thì thì em sẽ chỉ
việc là cái này anh chỉ thích lại gửi
cái mới thốt TechOne thế được cái kiểu J
cái router quay trở lại khi mà toàn bộ
những cái người ta đã nhập ở trên anh
địa chỉ đi tìm kiếm đang ở thứ thì khi
mà Remix điều hướng về thì quay trở lại
cái Trang đấy thôi thì nó sẽ không bị
làm sao cả
em phải đi trên chính là những cái cao
booking đi anh sẽ thử cho em xem mấy cái
Facebook King Arthur broca là đúng không
ạ
Vì
thế em sẽ thấy là toàn bộ những cái Minh
Điền lên thanh địa chỉ Mình sẽ được đẩy
ra thành địa chỉ thôi thì nó vẻ rất dài
như này cố tình kiểu làm loạn hết lên mà
để cái dài nữa bao gồm chưa cả nó biết
được Mình đến từ đâu có thử Google thì
chỉ đó nữa nhiều và nó tạo trong cái bọc
kem này tao cái này chị nó to cái kiểu
ngay từ lúc mình vào trang tao cái này
đã là là kiểu và gắn với bản thân mình
thì sau đó sự chất theo cái tóc em lại Ạ
kiếm tìm nha thấy không
xe tải Thế chị Đà Nẵng lấy không
đi theo
cả ngày giờ có thử tới mọi thứ đây có
thể là mấy thằng này nó không tách ra là
nhiều para có thể gộp chung như này xong
rồi nhưng mà cái format này phải rất là
chọn con không nghe mày tại Cao nhiều
pairing cũng được tùy em đấy
ảnh hài sắp xếp theo một cái gì đó như
này trả nợ cái này thì nó dùng lá sắc
chứ nó không dùng kiểu truyền lên thanh
địa chỉ Nhưng mà thường có thể đẩy nhanh
địa chỉ lại
khi cài ứng dụng rác mua rồi nhược điểm
Nếu mà dùng máy tắt nhà em không có điều
hướng quay trở lại được Hoàng Khiêm tải
lại trang sẽ mất mất cái mình vừa mình
vừa chọn từ tao không hay lắm nhưng mà
tại sao lại thế bởi vì đôi khi với một
cái hành trang đầu như này nhớ là nó
không muốn cái cái việc lót lại xa Thứ
hai nó là muốn là trôi theo kiểu là bởi
vì a những ngày này giá nó thường xuyên
thay đổi nó dao động và đôi khi mất vé
nè khi tại trang ah khi khi kiểu Khi mà
mình Duy đích điều hướng quay trở lại
đôi khi nó cái rồi đấy mẹ luôn đích bác
ấy đặc biệt remix bass là nó sẽ dùng cái
kiểu nút Bác của này họ sẽ lấy lại đúng
với giao diện cũ kể cả cho dù khi mà nó
không load lại dữ liệu mới đến đôi khi ở
người dùng sẽ
em thấy lại những cái váy cũ và giá rõ
ràng nó bị thay đổi rồi đấy do mà thằng
mấy thằng lỡ này có thể nó sẽ không muốn
nói lại tra hay không muốn điều hướng
quay trở lại mà nó sẽ dùng và sắp thôi
còn béo Mày làm cái cả đơn giản thì mình
sẽ cư loa vải xanh khi mà xử lý cái gì
đó cũng được không sao cả đấy
thì mới được nha
còn mấy câu truy vấn hay anh sẽ hỗ trợ
em sửa xong anh em về mấy cái đoạn mà
anh thấy nó bị nó bị sao ấy đúng không
em cảm thấy xin cái code này của em rất
bị loạn người khác mà Đọc cốt thoại của
em chẳng hiểu cái gì cả
ừ ừ
Nhưng mà im em lên ghi chú lại đây mà
bản chất là cái này em muốn em sẽ dụng
trong trường hợp này ví dụ trong trường
này nhá sẽ bao giờ
em sẽ ví dụ một thằng thì nó dễ hiểu là
kiểu ví dụ à thường anh sẽ ghi rõ này
nên nhóc sau đó đi chích này
thế thì làm như thế này thì người ta
người ta muốn tới đoạn này em xử lý nó
sẽ là kiểu bản chất kết quả cô ấy nó sẽ
là gì đấy Không không cần phải đôi khi
không cần phải thuộc dạng là cái phải
ghi rõ ràng cụ thể dài dòng từng bước
từng bước như nào cái Hà mày tác dụng gì
đôi khi các bạn hãy làm nó đơn giản nó
và kiểm dạ lúc đầu em truyền vào là như
thế này input như thế này sau đó thì đi
kiểu Asus là như này người dùng như phát
hiểu ngày à cả cái cả cái hàm này cốt là
để làm à Thế là xong đúng không Nói
chung là sao cho mà mình cũng đậm mình
cũng lười khi thủ thích cá hợp việc là
người khác cũng đỡ phải đọc nhiều đúng
không người ta cũng hiểu người ta nói
chung là sẽ đến mở cửa ra đạn là là
mình các bạn làm việc với nhau thì kiểu
gì Các bạn cũng hiểu biết TP em heo rồi
Giả sử thế đi giả sử thấy đi nghĩa người
ta vẫn thể đọc được cốt của em để hiểu
Nhưng mà đã không muốn đọc ra Muốn hiểu
Muốn Tóm tắt lại cả cái hàm của em đang
xử lý đầu vào gì đầu ra là gì Tin nhắn
để đấy thì người ta sẽ có thể bỏ qua
người ta sẽ có thể người ta giả sử người
ta đôi khi muốn viết tiếp hay thậm chí
về sau em quên cái gì đó em muốn viết
tiếp đoạn này em mới biết được rồi em sẽ
biết được à các ngài đang có kết quả là
gì Em có thể viết tiếp được chứ còn nếu
mà giờ sự bây giờ có ai vào bảo sữa cốt
của em và viết thêm một cái đoạn nào đó
để sửa một cái gì đó người ta sẽ phải
đọc từ đầu đến cuối bởi vì không biết
được đến cái loại này ấy biến này nó
đang nghĩa là gì Văn hiểu hiểu gì đó ông
đó là thì các bạn đang làm cốt là để cho
cốt chạy Ok Không sao cả Nhưng tôi vẫn
đang khuyên cho các bạn theo cái theo
cái hướng đó là mức của Suneo là là về
sau sẽ không sửa và tối ưu cốt nữa thì
cách suy nghĩ mà sẽ như thế nào sẽ là
cao đôi khi mà chúng ta phải
cô giáo khi làm về xong muốn sửa anh
muốn tôi yêu thì đó thì cái có sao cho
nó dễ hơn ý
ở ngay ở trên công ty thôi cũng thế mà
có rất nhiều Anh
Ừ đúng là anh ấy rất giọt Toán chuyên
môn cao có được thứ nhưng Viết cốt hơi
bị kiểu dạng nó trông nó rất phức tạp
thậm chí là anh đấy kết hợp với chung
cái vòng lọc các thứ em chụp vòng lặp
lòng nhau ở không đến nỗi nhưng mà ý à
cho một cái hót của ông này có của anh
rồi có chút cái một vòng lặp thật đấy
thì
Ừ lúc đấy ý Để mà ngồi vào sửa cốt của
anh ấy thực sự rất khó vì kiểu có rất
nhiều mảnh kết hợp với rất nhiều bộc lộ
cái tôi không biết được Kiểu đến thời
điểm hiện tại thì cái vòng lập đấy nó nó
là cái Nhầm cái mảnh Đấy nó đang có
những cái dữ liệu gì mình muốn thêm dữ
liệu vào thì mình sẽ phải thêm dữ liệu
vòng lặp nào em ạ đấy Nên là gì
Vì sao cho người dùng biết được cả ừ nó
đang như nào ra như thế nào đến vân thì
tốt rồi các thể thức để người ta bây giờ
trong trường hợp này ví dụ người lừa
Chúng tôi đã ngã Tao không muốn chạy thử
cốt đoạn này xem kết quả như nào Vân rồi
phải test nó cứ rất là mất công ở chung
nhà Thời gian ngồi cốt các bạn có thể
nhắn nhưng mà
À thế à skort luôn là giải hơn rất nhiều
nên mình luôn tính đến việc là khi sửa
code về sau nó sẽ lên như thế nào ạ
ok Nói chung à cái cái về với mấy câu
truy vấn thì tôi sẽ hỗ trợ sửa nhóm này
vì à Đó liên quan đến cho nhiều bạn thực
ra cho như vào hôm sau cả ở
cơ sở lại ví dụ ví dụ đây nha Thử ví dụ
luôn này thôi
Ừ thì có thể là sẽ deco này à
à à
ừ ừ
Ê thằng chú đi à
à à
Ừ
Thế em lấy cái này cốt để mà em lấy
jimin ship mà nho em quan tâm mình slot
với iPhone 5S tập thì em à
ở đây lại cái này chửi đi này à
Em
lầm là
Order
SQL excuses
anh
ờ ờ trong chở mày Anh muốn là lấy cái
khi mình đã đặt tên như này rồi em không
được à
ừ ừ
thế Mình vẫn phải que quay Loan à
hôm nay nó gọi một phát được luôn à
khi họ
là xong à
nha à
thì tại sao ngay từ lúc đầu ông không rõ
tên em lên như này đi
tất cả cá đấy nữa ừ
à à
anh
này vẫn đang để trong mạng như vậy
ừ ừ
Ừ cái thế là xong
Ừ
dạo này để mà kiểu như này là không muốn
không muốn
dùng cái ít nữa thì mình thể dùng quen
quen này copy rồi Bạn ấy
ừ ừ
MT I
I MT có điểm rất hay ở ngoài việc kiểm
tra xem nó có tô tải không cần tra xem
nó còn kiểm tra được nó giá trị dẫn có
nhiều thương nữa nên rất là ôi
Em
thích giới thiệu 12 về đi tắm luôn cả
cái kiểu nhanh nhé
có mỗi chứ
ít cá thứ dưới đấy
trên như thế này sau đó đến cho này
đây Bye quấy này
kia chưa Ừ
time này nằm ở đâu ở perth
a router này từ
ở mô tơ này nằm ở trong cái a a
Em xài đúng không Thường ngày hôm trước
tôi bảo đấy thường là mình có thể làm
ngay từ lúc đầu mình có thể là kiểu giới
hạn những cái này trước khi mà trôi vào
thì mình sẽ là
ờ ờ
Ơi Xuân À
à à
em
Gợi ý Xin vãi
ờ ờ on
à à
ạ sau đó thì à
Nghe thời sự hôm qua này à
à à
Ừ sáng nay đi
như thế này đấy nhé cũng bắt chước ngay
là được
đi xe châu Á
mẹ
cho rồi đi
ừ ừ
à à
anh vẫn yêu cái gì cả đó
xe Mercedes
à à
Ừ thế que tham quay bếp này mình có thể
rút gọn nó lại thành như thế này ờ
cơ
hội như này
tiếp theo thì
sẽ nhỏ hơn
thì tại sao như thế bởi vì à Như hôm
trước tôi nói nếu mà dùng cằm hàm que
que bếp và wavethai như này thì nó sẽ
không tận dụng được Index của cái thằng
này còn khi bạn dùng kiểu kiểu như này
thì bạn sẽ tận dụng được Index của hai
cái cục này của cô này thôi đấy thì cái
này ngày tháng năm mà đúng không năm sau
đó mình sẽ nối chỗ bây giờ phút giây
đúng không Không có so sánh thời gian
như này So sánh thời gian ngay được
ừ ừ
cao ve que vô chứ cho ông rồi đấy
khi trói
đã có câu chuyện cho nó sạch khẩu là như
thế này cũng khá là dày có thể tông cái
này vào trong cái á như trước tôi là
trong mua đồ hạn chế độ để nó ngày nhờ
Thôi tùy
Nghe ca nhạc
dạo này chả tôi để mua qua Thế thì về
các bạn nhìn thấy biết cách để tối ưu
thôi
chứ thực ra thì
ừ ừ
em gà thì
nếu nó chạy được rồi vẫn nên giữ nguyên
nhưng mà chắc chắn về sau các bạn sẽ có
thể thắc mắc kiểu các thứ thứ thì các
bạn đây là những cái buổi mà các bạn thì
kiểu xem để tham khảo
và những cái này tôi biết từ đâu đến nhờ
tôi phải tiếp xúc nhiều kết hợp và bảo
tôi luôn nghĩ là có cách nào tối ưu được
thế mới không tôi sẽ tôi sẽ luôn lót
những câu truy vấn ra để tôi kiểm tra
các thông số thứ Để xem tối ưu nữa kết
hợp việc là tôi cũng phải mua thêm một
vài khóa học
chuyên bên là leo trong cái quần xong
rồi Kiểu equus có thử thứ Nói chung vào
cái gì nhưng mà tôi xem xong rồi tục
chia sẻ lại cho mấy ông này có gì có gì
hay ho rồi chia sẻ lại nhau nhé á
anh
nghe tại sao cứ cứ ham biến nó lại
Android làm gì à
luôn thích ở quần hơn anh em thích
Collection hơn là Android
Ừ tự nhiên là vẫn muốn cậu có thể truyền
cái cảnh như này à
à nhưng cái này nó có dùng tận dụng X có
thể gọi ngay đây gọi ý theo cầu đối
tượng nó cho nó đẹp hơn mà viết một ngắn
hơn nhỉ
à à
ờ ờ
theo kịp theo kỳ và như nào bạn nhỉ Bạn
chất thì các bạn cứ làm xong rồi có gì
mình sẽ chữa chấm như cá nhóm như này
thôi
đương nhiên là không
và đương nhiên là bạn sẽ không theo kịp
trước cửa là livestream trực tiếp ngay
được một vì chính các bạn còn đang học
này các bạn còn khó theo vì mình đang
dạy đến mức chân sau rồi nâng cao rồi
còn
thì các bạn cứ làm đồ ăn bình thường các
bạn có thể inbox riêng mình để mình sẽ
chữa thế thôi
ở nhóm nào cần muốn chữa gì thêm nữa
không nhỉ chữa cốt này không phải chữa
tài liệu có dư thứ 8 rồi hộ hôm hôm
trước tôi mới thấy à có bạn hỏi là có
cần làm Powerpoint Không lắng nghe
thuyết trình các bạn đâu phải làm
passport rồi chúng loạn
và làm Powerpoint thì sẽ la lá giống đổi
một mà kiểu có vài cái nó sẽ đổ cần nằm
trên PowerPoint vài cái không thì cái
này bạn tham khảo tới đón một mình
à à
level rồi
Ừ vậy thôi Ở đó chị mới các bạn với mình
cái chai cát rồi
bố mẹ tôi sẽ ngồi
Xóa bớt đi
Lưu Lưu thời gian ở trong BB ga có rất
nhiều kiểu Lư thời gian trong B
Các bạn thấy là từ có thể đét này ngày
tháng năm này tham này tôi sẽ từ M đến
mày không xem luôn nha
là tôi không nhớ cụ thể có tất cả bao
nhiêu Tôi sẽ thử mở trong mình xem ạ ạ
khi hạ tha mày có bếp này tha mày yêu à
tôi biết có cái gì ạ
Ô hay nhỉ
Anh Dương tôi không Mày biết có cái đấy
ở cùng cũng tiện
ừ ừ
à à
nếu mà hai số chỉ có dao động từ 70 cho
đến
369 Phạm Trưởng
đã có 46 rồi Ờ vết tham này timestamp
này không ạ thì theo các bạn
Ừ để tôi thử hỏi lại xem các bạn có nhớ
không theo các bạn thì mình nên lưu lại
thời gian
Ừ nếu mà có giờ phút giây ngày tháng 5
nhé chứ không phải lưu lại kiểu mỗi ngày
tháng năm nữa nhé Và thậm chí đôi khi cả
ngày tháng năm luôn thì mình nên lưu lại
là những kiểu như nào bếp này tham này
cái đít sao mà ai timestamp in được
không Nói rồi Ở đây tôi sẽ bố ứng dụng
lại đi thể bỏ qua
khi tôi đọc lại tôi thì nó lại câu hỏi
nhé
Ừ
ngày mai nộp em nói lại gọi này à
thức các bạn ạ nếu
cần phải lưu thời gian trong d b
bà cụ thể và
ngày tháng năm giờ phút giây
thì các bạn chọn kiểu dữ liệu nào ờ
Ừ ok googel in fact in nuclear dịch
à à
tải thơ ca ngay cái câu hỏi này các bạn
đã thấy nó có tí
hỏi
hỏi hỏi mẹo rồi và đương nhiên câu trả
lời nó sẽ là tham tem chứ chứ không nhỉ
Nếu mà giả sử nó hiển nhiên là đến ham
vì nó không hỏi ở đây làm gì cả đúng bạn
ạ
mà tại sao lại lưu để thêm tem Bởi vì
khi mà bạn lưu lại thăm Xem đôi khi
không cần phải ngày tháng năm rồi phút
giây các bạn lưu lại mỗi ngày tháng năm
thôi Tôi khuyên mà ông nên lưu ở thăm
xem có giữ nếu mà lưu giờ phút đây Đúng
là nên là tham thôi thật tại sao như thế
bởi vì khi tham tem bạn lưu lại là một
con nó làm một cái dãy số số dây vậy từ
1997 không phải cho đến thời điểm hiện
tại thì cái số rồi đấy
các bạn lưu lại kiểu như thế thì bạn sẽ
đỡ phải mất công Converse ở
Ừ nếu mà giờ sửa bếp Tham như này bạn
Nếu bạn muốn convert đó sao một cái gì
kiểu gì khác thì bạn sẽ lại phải biến nó
lại thành timestamp rồi bạn với con bớt
được thay mình như thế thì ngay từ lúc
đầu bạn còn bạn convert nó luôn là kiểu
dữ liệu
và bạn muốn biến nó thành cái kiểu gì
bạn muốn sau này đều được đấy
Vì thế nên là thường là lưu lại thăm xem
đứng yên nó có một tí nhược điểm đó là
với một vài cái hiển thị dữ liệu thì
việc lưu lại không xem thì nó sẽ Nó là
một dãy số này Lúc mà bạn vào tay bạn
khó đọc nhưng mà với thằng head ít này
thì thì nó lại tự động convert timestamp
thành kiểu ngày tháng năm giống phút
giây rồi nên là bạn vào xem.ao bay vẫn
dễ đọc như bình thường chứ nếu mà dùng
cái TP má mi đúng là dùng tham Xem ông
gặp nhìn thấy một loạt dãy số 19 bao
nhiêu thì không không đọc được không
biết Cụ thể hôm đấy Hôm nào đúng ạ đấy
thì
Anh thường là
chúng ta sẽ luôn dùng kem step đối với
Dash và đến tham Còn với tham với nhân
vẫn lên là than thôi Ok chị ạ
Ừ khi nào tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các ông đi
Troy đẩy cốc lên nhưng mà Bởi vì cái
trang web thì cái trang web cái web môi
giới việc làm gì vậy để bây giờ vẫn chưa
xong ở chưa xong nóng lẽ là nó phải sau
nữa nhưng mà có vẻ gần đây ạ
anh ở một tuần nữa mình dự định một tuần
nữa bảo vệ rồi nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi Đúng rồi Tôi dự định một tuần
nữa mà mẹ mà
ạ bây giờ tốt không biết cốt mấy ông là
hình như thế nào
bảo đến hôm nay bảo vệ nhưng có vẻ vẫn
vẫn có vài ngày hôm chưa bảo vệ chưa đâu
lâu cả ờ ờ
anh nói chung là để hôm sau thôi sẽ chấm
lần lượt các nhóm các thứ thứ bảo phải
thử các từ thứ Xem Nói chung duyệt lại
phát nữa Từ tài liệu lẫn cả
bảo vệ thử cả tài liệu đi cũng được và
ban cốt để xem các nhóm có sẵn sàng cho
hôm thứ bảy tuần sau nha không đi lại
phải đầy nuôi lịch đấy đâu ạ
quan đến cài đặt kit lỗi nhưng mà tôi
quên sư mất Cái lỗi của bạn ấy thì chị
ra gì rồi anh nhớ mang máng nó liên quan
việc là
phiên bản nó lỗi phiên bản cho Để kia
bạn nào hỏi lại tôi tôi sẽ trả lời kỹ
thêm
ô ô check
cho IP id.com encourage chap sau đi
cái carbon này nhờ tôi từng nói qua mấy
ông nhiều rồi
carbonell đó là cái Pocket kiểu thư viện
kiểu chuyên để làm việc với đấy với cái
dữ liệu thời gian mà Mấy ông thường hay
thấy tôi làm rồi bao gồm cả nó rất là có
rất nhiều hàm dưới là hai việc làm thêm
tuần này à
em lấy khoảng một khoảng thời gian nào
đó
anh có thể cộng thêm một tháng cộng thêm
một năm hay gì gì đó lấy ngày đầu tiên
trong tháng thì đó rất nhiều
thấy khá xịn
Có
ai đã về Pocket của carbon
em có kiểu nó liên quan kiểu với làm
việc với thời gian thì các bạn sẽ thử
nhiều đến các Pan
Anh thường là mấy ông sẽ nghĩ việc là
uốn nick để mà cậu ờ ờ
Anh tên Lộc Trung lúa à nhầm để nó duy
nhất và đôi khi là mình sẽ kiểu dạng là
mình muốn để cho nó duy nhất kiểu thậm
chí Hồi trước có bạn bảo với tôi là sử
là bạn ấy kiểu muốn cho
hạn sau đó bạn muốn bảo là em sẽ để
Yoona cả nội dung bài đăng bởi vì à cậu
em không muốn được nội dung bài đang bị
lặp lại nhưng tại sao nó lại bảo lỗi hả
anh ấy khi mà để thay là dạng Tech thì
các bạn sẽ không đểu không để được và
không nên để uống nước
ở nick ở trên tay bản chất là nó sẽ luôn
đó làm cái Index và nó luôn kiểm tra lại
kiểu toàn bộ rà soát lại một lượt trong
DB kiểu đã đã có chưa nóng lạnh khi mà
bạn mày ngu nick cho cái cột thì thay là
tách ra nó không cho phép rồi thì không
khác gì nó ngồi kiểm tra từ từng chữ một
trong cái đoạn văn bản cũng dài đấy cả
mẹ thường không ai làm thế Cả tương tự
Thế các bạn sẽ không nên would bay theo
dạng Tech
bởi vì Goodbye bản chất ở nó cũng sẽ
hiểu
tìm kiếm xong rồi lọc trùng cá thứ đây
là riêng về mấy cái trường hợp liên quan
đến 2 tách thì trừ ra mình không nên xử
lý đến cái cột đấy nên giữ nguyên còn
đấy thôi khi
bé khi mà ông xuất dữ liệu ra khi ông xử
lý gì đó ở trong nhà để kiểm tra đạo văn
hai cái gì nó dùng database kiểm tra sẽ
ông chết đây ông sẽ nên kiểm tra một cái
khác
để làm những cái kiểu kiểm tra Mấy cái
kiểu theo liên quan đến cuộc tách nhá À
đúng rồi một kiểu dữ liệu dạng khách
nói về cái gì
à à
Anh ở shopping này thôi nhớ à Ờ có một
cách hay để mà lưu để tôi chỉ cho mấy
ông ạ
vì tôi nghĩa của tôi đang cân nhắc việc
đã không biết nên nói cái rất tinh này
Hôm nay không
tại vì hôm nay mày không biết là đủ kiến
thức để các bạn
ăn sáng chưa Ăn sáng rồi mình tặng nhỉ
mày Thật ra tôi đang mới nhẹ nhàng thôi
Tôi không muốn điều đó nói thêm nhiều
kích thước quá nó bị quá tải
việc à tôi vẫn chính bản thân tôi cũng
đang trong tai nạn
vẫn ngày nghỉ mấy ngày hôm nay không đậu
một phút mấy ông động cốt chỉ công ty
Kiều Thực ra đấy là đấy là nhược điểm
khi mà mình à
à mình mình đôi khi mình không vào buồng
mình đang trong lại Hãy nghỉ nhiều quá
Mình sẽ bị lừa rồi bị lười này mình rất
khó được cưỡng lại cái lừa đây nhưng mà
một khi mình ăn trong cuồng cha mẹ thì
mình sẽ là chăm mình cảm đầy kiểu
em làm bao nhiêu cũng cũng được không
biết mấy ông kiểu thấy không Chúng tôi
là kiểu thế nghĩa là nếu mà tôi mà lỡ
lười rồi Thôi lười lắm cậu mấy ngày
không làm việc cho thử thứ thoải mái cho
kia hình sự chán chẳng biết gì làm gì
lúc đấy sẽ xem xét đương nhiên là vẫn
vẫn cảm thấy đôi khi là tôi không muốn
mà bản thân mình vô dụng nỗi ở Cả ngày
chỉ ngồi chơi rồi
à à
anh đợi tôi tí đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ ok thì tôi sẽ có vẻ các bạn muốn nghe
tiếp thì thế tôi xin phép nói nốt cái
này sắp đi làm một cái rất là hay
ô t bây giờ để tôi thử ví dụ méo nhé à
Ừ vợ tôi sẽ mở sao lên
Ừ tôi sẽ lấy ví dụ đúng như đúng như ở
trên công ty tôi đang bị đi Thế mày ông
dễ hình Dung rất nhiều công ty bị đeo
màu bảo dơ đóng lại mình sẽ cột ID và
còn ai đi mình thường mấy ông để như nào
nhỉ Nó là kiểu số lâu nhất và nó là như
thế nào nó tự đọc Băng đúng không
auto-increment Tự động tăng gai đúng
không
ý Thì cái này nó nó sẽ có rất nhiều cái
tiện liên quan đến việc nếu để tự động
tăng và số thứ nhất là số thì nó sẽ là
kẹo nó kêu dưới điện nó nhẹ Ok thứ hai
là khi để tự động tăng như này thì ông
sẽ hoàn toàn biết được là người nào đăng
ký trước ngày nào các buổi thứ vỡ ối đầu
Ngọn Cờ
à Thế à Thế nhưng
thế nhưng nó sẽ bị nhược điểm đó là kiểu
ở cái này bán nãy bán nãy nó không nên
có một nhược điểm mà cả cho đến khi nó
sinh nó là ông có nhiều máy chủ ở nhiều
nơi
cho ví dụ ví dụ ở tôi đang tôi đang ở
Việt Nam đúng không ạ Nếu giả sử là tôi
thì có người dùng là người Việt Tôi để
máy chủ là ở Việt Nam luôn người dùng
kết nối từ từ Việt Nam đến máy chủ ở
Việt Nam được nhiều sẽ cùng anh đúng
không ạ Không có vấn đề gì cả tự nhiên
về sau tôi mới làm Đa Quốc gia đấy thế
Tôi muốn
tôi muốn là người Mỹ ở tít ở bên kia bán
cầu vẫn có thể hiểu sử dụng mình trang
web của tôi ai thì đương nhiên là khi mà
họ và trong web của mình là đồng nghĩa
việc là họ muốn học kết nối để cái máy
chủ của mình loạn nếu mà ông chị có để
máy chủ ở Việt Nam thôi thì họ cái nổi
máy chủ của tôi dưới ở lâu rồi xử lý là
lâu nóng lạnh khiến lo hiểu ở tốc độ nó
sẽ bị giả Thì bây giờ mình sẽ phải làm
như nào Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ đến để
máy chủ ở bên Mỹ đúng không làm thì mỗi
có ra một cái mấy giờ đi đúng không Thì
nó lại nhảy sinh tình trạng nó liên quan
đến bất đồng bộ
khi bất đồng bộ tất cả sao nghĩa là hai
cái có thể không cập nhật cùng cùng một
lúc và có loạn nó sẽ liên quan đến bất
đồng bộ và tất là sao ví dụ Giả sử là
nếu mà vẫn để ai đi tự động tăng như thế
I love máy chủ của Việt Nam tôi đang là
một đúng không ạ xong rồi máy chủ của
tôi tự nhiên người dùng ở Việt Nam đăng
ký nữa thì nó nhảy lên làm hai nhưng mà
đồng thời đồng thời ở bên Mỹ cũng có
người đăng ký và Lúc đầu Lúc đầu máy chủ
ở bên đấy Cái lúc mà nó đăng kiểm tra
cài đặt ấy bay của mình nó vẫn đang là
nó vẫn đang làm 1
Vì thế nên là nó sẽ mặc định tăng lên mà
nó ngon thì nó sẽ là hai đúng ạ nó tăng
lên là hay rồi khiến cho hai thằng cùng
bị chung ID ngỡ như là trong durabase
khóa chính nó không được phép lại đúng ạ
Họ sẽ báo lỗi rồi đấy Cái thứ nhất thứ
hai đó lại đây trong trường hợp mà ông
tách ông muốn gộp chung đã tăng bay vào
trong một cái nhé Còn nếu ông Táo tàu
bay kiểu là máy chủ ở ở Mỹ một gió bay
mái chùa Việt Nam một tay thì không thì
tôi không nói nhá Đấy đây vụ Hồi trước
tôi từng nói Instagram tội từng thứ ba
tôi từng nói qua về cái vụ này một lần
rồi Instagram từng làm vụ từng cho mọi
người đọc hoài Town chỉnh kịp lóc rồi
nhưng mà tôi muốn nói lại và theo tôi sẽ
nói bao gồm cả cốt nữa nhé đấy theo cách
xử lý ở công ty tôi thì như thế nào
về tiếp tục đó là Ok thế thì bây giờ Làm
thế nào để mà kiểu
ạ Bây giờ nếu mà ở đây nó sẽ có xảy ra
hay tình huống mà Mấy ông muốn làm ở
công ty tôi áp dụng cả hai tình huống
đấy thứ nhất một là ông vẫn muốn ai đi
là số và nó nên vẫn có cái gì đó tăng tự
động
chẳng qua là kiểu nó không nên trùng với
cái máy chủ ở Quốc ở khu vực khác hiểu
không nghĩa nó vẫn sẽ tăng tự động và nó
vẫn là số để sao cho khi mà người dùng
vào xem ID Hả Cái gì đó người dùng sẽ
nhớ cái đi bản thân mình kết hợp với
việc là mình nhìn và ID mình cũng sẽ
phân biệt được cả à bây giờ lượng người
dùng Ồ một khu vực đang tối đa là bao
nhiêu rồi cái hở việc là người nào đăng
ký trước người nào Cái thứ đấy Đều nắm
được không cần phải dùng câu truy vấn ở
cao không phải không phải ngồi kiểm tra
cái cột led mất nữa méo hiểu do thì Ừ
cái đấy nên xử lý như nào đấy
anh nghe sao tình trường hợp Một nha
Ừ thôi đi Tôi cứ ghi ra cái đã
Ồ sao vậy tách thì mấy ông dễ hình dung
nhé
Ê mày ông theo được đoạn nào không theo
được bạn nào thì bảo tôi rằng kỹ lại nhé
Cho một mà à
đúng không ạ Trông như có chút cái máy
chủ thì không định để xấu nhưng
vẫn giữ là số này để cho nó nhẹ đúng chứ
số thứ 2 là ờ ờ
anh vẫn muốn nó tự động tăng à
tôi đứng như là điều này không thể theo
cả dùng trong Word và không để tự động
tăng nó sẽ bị lắp đấy không không không
chịu trên theo đồng dưa hồng đấy thứ hai
cái với Tại sao muốn tự động đăng bởi
việc nắm rõ
số lượng đã đăng ký là ạ
chị đã đang đang có đang có
treo từng khu vực chẳng hạn thế kết hợp
việc là phân biệt
được
thằng nào trước thằng nào sau nó trước
sau rối loạn đấy
rất là dễ trường hợp là dùng
cái kiểu ID duy nhất
hãy gọi là USD không ạ thì rất là dễ thì
tôi sẽ trả lời cái dễ cho nghe Ok nếu
mày ông muốn trả lời đi Trả lời dễ trước
khi nó sẽ là mình sẽ mình cách để mình
xử lý nó sẽ đơn giản thôi mình sẽ ví dụ
là giả sử ví dụ cốt của bạn này luôn nhá
thì mình sẽ là mình sẽ tạo một cái
khi mình xử lý Cốt sau khi mà giả sử với
cái thông mua đồ này khi mình muốn thêm
một thằng nào đó thì mình sẽ là
bút thì phải
chứ không chuyển boot được nha
Aguero Quân à
bộ xử lý Vân
em hết bắt sự kiện là khi mình mình thêm
thêm một thằng đó
ở tại Đà Lạt
Em ở đó không Có phải không vậy cho nó
mua đồ nhé
khi sex
Ừ rồi con chắc luôn
phải là ngày
Tôi đang muốn là viết trong thằng mua đồ
nhá ông thể tách riêng nhạc được theo
kiểu sơ nhưng mà tôi em mở ra gộp chung
vào thì sẽ như nào đây lại
cô gái áo xanh đây à
Lý
Hải mặc định là cứ gọi parent để điều
hiển nhiên này theo khi mà khi mà khởi
tạo này đúng không Thì nếu mà làm cái
kiểu đơn giản làm kiểu dùng mua đi rồi
rất đơn giản là mình sẽ bị sẽ kiểu ghi
đề đó ngày ID rồi nó
là làm USD thì nhớ là có nhớ không làm
lạ
thằng pê nó sẽ có khu IV nó sẽ là này
Ừ cái hàng này nó có thể thêm cả ràng
buộc cho nó kiểu more Nitơ amôn kiểu để
chắc chắn nào cho nó là duy nhất nữa cơ
bạn có thể thêm prefix là cái gì đó Fix
là sự ông muốn thêm một cái tiền tố một
cái chữ gì đó thường có thể U như thế
này tôi thường thêm ô cho cách dứa ngay
cái kiểu thế u gạch dưới là giống thằng
idiot nghỉ
hay sao thêm Chu thì chắc chắn là nó sẽ
kèo sẽ thêm về sự cho sẽ tôi sẽ thử cho
mình xem
a cho cái chai thu của ông
Anh hello nhỉ
mấy ông xem được cốt này luôn
Mẹ của tôi đi
nghe Danh Hài
giờ tôi vào bên à
đã test Ngọc sẽ tạo cái test này à
chị sẽ là à à
other
Ông gọi 20 xô rồi không được à
trò chuyện lạ email của nó và ví dụ là
test giờ chẳng hạn Lý Hải
Ừ tôi sẽ Google này à
ừ ừ
sau
khi này nó sẽ trả về gái đi nó sẽ chạy
qua cái thằng nào
ở Xuân Mai
A Gọi lỗi
em gái nó sẽ trả nó sẽ truyền ai đi vì
kiểu này tiền Tố Như này việc à Nếu mà
thêm Chu như này nó sẽ kiểu dạng là chỗ
thêm cả đống chấm rồi Một đống sao ngay
à
đây tôi bị lỗi vì hết cột của tôi ai đi
rồi tôi đang là số thế là không được
thế nhưng đây là cách dễ thì cách này
các bạn thấy à Ok nó chắc chắn để không
bị chồng nhưng mà nó sẽ cho nó sẽ không
để tự động tăng kết hợp được à
cái việc cả nó không
mình không dễ nhìn không dễ nhìn người
dụng khó nhớ thế làm thế nào thì ở nó
cho một vẫn giữ nguyên là số để tự động
tăng thì cách làm ở đây nó sẽ như thế
này
ở đầu tiên chỉ à
thì nó sẽ khái niệm bản chất là cái sát
này
khi cài đặt achat này là nó là phân Tuấn
bộ phân bố gì đó mới Tôi dịch na ná hiểu
nó ra thế thì tôi thường nghe lưu thêm
một cái đó là xác ID nghĩa tôi lưu lại
là cái
a
Sharp ID như thế này
Ừ để mình biết được à Cái người dùng
đăng ký này nằm ở khu vực nào vậy cái
thứ nhất thứ hai đó là thứ hai đó là
mình sẽ nối cái sáng lại đi này mới chí
ngay đi lúc đầu của người dùng
Hôm nọ mình sẽ đến toàn bộ tất cả người
dùng trong khôi phục khu vực đấy ví dụ
giả sử ở sự nhé Ở Việt Nam tôi thường
cái đấy là mười này ở Mỹ Rồi 20 này đấy
ạ sau đó thì ở Korea khác tới đến 30 chị
gì đó như này nó sẽ có mơ trông rồi nhá
xe tải số tôi sẽ nối cái này đầu tiên
tôi sẽ ngồi kiểm tra
ở Tà người dùng ở nằm ở trong khu vực à
Tôi sẽ đến là người người người dùng nằm
ở trong khu vực kiểu Việt Nam trở ngại
có bạn nào chưa
ô nhiễm vào chưa thì mình sẽ là mình sẽ
cứ mặc định trong nó vòng 1 sẽ làm 10
một này cái tiếp theo
người dùng tiếp theo thì mình một không
hai như thế này Cái thứ tư sẽ lên nó cứ
đếm và cậu lên đương nhôm được đến liên
tục ngày nó sẽ bị nặng đã ra tay khi
mình đến quá nhiều nên thường tôi cách
nó lại nghe tôi sẽ đến rồi cách nó lại
đánh nó sẽ như thế này sẽ là mắc ID này
bằng cách thường mà tôi sẽ để lưu sẽ là
một khoảng thời gian thường là chọn trí
forever cũng được nhưng mà như tôi từng
bảo mấy ông để nó chắc thì mình sẽ không
lên hãy hạn chế forever thì mình sẽ u xơ
xạ
à à mắt ai đi được tiền như này được đấy
Sau đó thì mình sẽ
có thể hiểu thỉnh thoảng đếm lại cũng
được nhưng mà không cần phải có bó việc
đến liên tục lại nhiều lắm 60 X60 nhân à
à 24 ngân hàng mà đã 6 năm ngày là xử
thế
em ra đây có số là thật à lưu lại mà nhẹ
phát triển ở đây mình sẽ ở đây là
à à
mình sẽ trồng quýt ơn về
là
sao
không đi xe được không sao được xe chính
ra thằng ngu do Này quay đi
cho đến where
e băng cái đoạn này nó ra hai này Thế
rốt cuộc ông Làm thế nào để không biết
được là ok cái khu vực của ông
đá banh là ở đâu đấy ông Quen như thế
nào một việc cái cốt này của ông sẽ dùng
ở Việt Nam dùng mỹ dùng bất kỳ quốc gia
khác thì cái này là cái mà mọi người cần
nên biết đó là bản chất là cái file nv
này sinh ra nó nó viết tắt của in và
mình đã và Môi trường rất là sao Cái này
nó không phải ngoài việc cấu hình lúc
đầu cho cái trang của ông chạy đâu mà nó
cấu hình để cho theo tùy từ máy chủ của
ông nữa ví dụ với cái máy chủ này tôi sẽ
có là sát
Có ai đi Bằng
10tr Việt Nam thì mình sẽ lấy Cảnh Sát
hay đi học người ra từ nv đấy tiếp theo
là
a tiếp theo là Kiều với á với ở Mỹ hiện
tôi sẽ sửa lại con số này thành 20 có
thử thứ sau đó đây tôi sẽ lấy đúng là
tôi không nên chọc Thằng Hải nói V như
này mà tôi sẽ lấy qua từ confix nhưng mà
thôi đoạn này thôi chị mấy ông thì nó sẽ
lấy cua nv rồi ngay
cái chai đi nha cái
sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy mắt cái đi của nó
được à
chị đánh mắt đi này thử cái là nó cũng
anh ở đây nó sẽ có hai trường hợp nữa
số 1 là giả sử là nếu mà chưa có như tôi
bảo thì tôi sẽ kết hợp với sát cho cậu
ra mặc định cho nó một đoạn nó sẽ như
thế này
anh đã không bao gồm bình tĩnh lấy ra đã
tới kiểm tra là ít ít nôn là sửa Nếu
không có
Ừ thì mình sẽ có ai đi bằng
thôi nghĩa là tôi sẽ
Sharp hay đi bằng
đi đâu về đây luôn đi Tôi sẽ dùng nó một
vài lần nữa
em
còn đây eo thì mình sẽ có mắt hay đi
cộng cộng
ai đi bằng
Ừ thế là được à
theo trai đi này nếu mà nó không ra cái
gì cả
Ừ nó luôn thì mình sẽ nổi với cái khác
hay đi lúc đầu xong rồi tăng xong rồi
cho nối với số 1 Còn nếu mà có rồi
thì mình chỉ cần tăng lên 16 mình sẽ
kiểu Nga thế là xong
khi cây chưa
ai thì tôi phải tạo thêm cột nữa tôi mới
test được cho mấy ông thực đơn cả là
phải reset hả MV mỗi lần chạy nữa cho
mấy ông hiểu được hiểu là qua cơ chế nào
em nhỉ
Đấy thì cơ chế ở đây con sẽ là mình sẽ
vừa nắm rõ được cả việc à Mới khu vực
nào thì cái lựa cái lượng người dùng đã
đăng ký ở trên trang đấy là bao nhiều
loại nó giống kiểu tự động tăng của mình
sự kết hợp việc làm kiểu là mình
mình sẽ luôn tăng số em cái số là nó sẽ
không Bảo Chung được cái số hay đâu nha
Lúc nào sửa về sau lên mình có số gạo đó
dù có số này Ví dụ ở lên đến cậu Mười đi
thì nó sẽ là những cái xong rồi lên 20
mà trông nó sẽ không ngờ có thế
thì nó sẽ không bao giờ thì bị trùng
hoặc con số này nó cứ thể tăng tăng tăng
lên thì thôi thử cái này chỉ bị hơn mà
nhược điểm tí ông nhìn lúc đầu nó sẽ bị
mất cái mất khá tiện bị dài thêm hai cái
số đầu thử thôi nhưng ngoài ra không sao
cả thực là áp dụng
áp dụng được chính Hằng Facebook là một
điển hình cái ID Facebook của mình lúc
đầu đầu số nó sẽ 10.000 thì phải cái gì
đó
nếu để không ạ
Mỗi thằng Facebook thì nó cho cây trời
khác khi mà nó sẽ cứ cho mặc định là
lunar 10.000 thế này ở một hàng có số
dày Nhai xong rồi Nếu mà người dùng tăng
thì sẽ cậu đổi số ngày gọi sơ đồ số nhà
đối sống như thế này thôi Về sau thể đủ
nói anh như thế này đúng ạ
khi con kiểu mình làm cho đơn giản hơn
là mình cộng thẳng vào thì mình đỡ mới
cấp đổi số nữa thì mình sẽ ở trên rằng
tăng nó như này xong rồi dán vào sau
đấy nhớ số mình về sau sẽ số nó khá là
trông có này rất dài nhờ kiểu mình kiểu
bikini này được cao tôi Nghĩa không phải
lo vấn đề lắm sao về sau cũng không bị
lỗi hơn 1 tỉ dùng đâu không tìm cái dùng
kết hợp con số này là 10 tỷ nó không hẳn
là dài lắm không phải lo
Ừ Ok mày không hiểu là đoạn này được nhỉ
em có màu thắc mắc gì không ạ
ty tôi làm
với hai trường hợp với trường hợp kiểu
muốn Nếu giả sử là kiểu muốn chỉ đơn
giản là kiểu để tránh chồng mình dùng
Huawei đi Thôi được rồi nếu vẫn muốn giữ
số thì tôi sẽ hiểu dùng cách lưu lại như
thế này thì hạn chế được đến mềm lại
đúng ạ Đấy sau đó thì mình là
xong đấy
chả bỏ mày tạm dừng Nói nha
hai vợ chồng béo ra
đấy thì mày Ông cứ sắp sửa dân cho đồ ăn
đi Có gì thắc mắc thì phải hỏi luôn nhé
Ừ không thì ở bùi thứ ba sau sẽ bảo vệ
thử nói cho Bảo vị thượng dần dần dần đi
loạn cái nhỉ
à à